right well I you know again I'm a
practicing psychiatrist and I think that
I really believe in the advances of
psychiatry our diagnoses are more
precise they get more precise with every
volume of the diagnostic manual our
treatments slowly get better over time
and I'm not adverse to saying that there
are biological bases to mental illness
I'm part of a department that does a lot
of fantastic research in brain imaging
scans other kinds of genetic research
that really looks at mental illness
seemingly below the level of culture
context race ethnicity at the level of
brain structures that are seemingly the
same in all people and at the same time
I feel like there's a false divide
almost like you have to vote is an
illness biological or is it social or
socially constructed and and I I don't
like that divide very much because I
think that all definitions of illness
and maybe particularly all definitions
of psychiatric illness are always are
always both it doesn't have to be one of
the other mental illness is a real thing
it has real material consequences for
people who suffer from it and at the
same time even the most biological
finding reflects social social context
in very important ways and so I think
psychiatry is better off looking both at
biology and at social contexts and
really trying to think of the
relationship between those and I think
doctors and patients are better off that
way we certainly know that depression is
an illness all you have to do is watch
an antidepressant advertisement on
television right now and think about why
might it be that a person might see an
ad like that what are the forces that
are leading them to go in and ask a
doctor in part in part it might be that
that ad speaks to some symptoms they're
having that are chemical symptoms but
you many of these ads play off of
familiar cultural stereotypes about
gender or parenting or social class
other kinds of things and so I think
doctors need to be aware of both that
depression as one example is an illness
that has a chemical basis but also is
deeply embedded in cultural norms about
gender social class race so that would
be one example there's great work that's
been done now on bipolar disorder by
emily martin here at nyu and looking at
the kind of cultural basis of bipolar
disorder obsessive compulsive disorder
after the show monk for instance is
something that there's a lot of popular
conversation about and so i think again
it's true for all illness but it's
certainly true for psychiatric illness
that these illnesses often reflect
cultural norms in addition to biological
realities and really we have to be
fluent in both
well again I I think that we're we're
making a mistake if we don't see that
there's a cultural basis too many
illnesses not just psychiatric ones
breast cancer would be one prevalent
example right now different kind of
cultures surrounding it if you don't
understand the cultural meaning of an
illness like that you're gonna you're
gonna miss the boat even if you're a
great scientist so I don't think it's
the case that it's just psychiatric
disorders but we know from history that
when we get the ultimate you know cure
for a particular illness or nail it down
it stops being a psychiatric illness and
then it's taken up by internal medicine
or you know we know oh it was just an
iron imbalance or it was a vitamin
deficiency or something like that that
in a way it's taken away from psychiatry
and taken taken to medicine but but I
think that's you know if you look at
diagnostic rates and treatment rates in
psychiatric disorders it's it's even
with all the controversy about SSRIs
right now the the improvement rates are
reasonably good compared to other
medical specialties and so I think it's
it's always going to be a negotiation
about what's the best way to understand
psychiatric illness but of course the
flip side of that is that there is this
aura of it's something we don't know in
a certain kind of way and so psychiatry
is always kind of fighting against that
and probably that's why we had a move
toward saying things are slowly
biological in a certain kind of way is
to you know rightly move toward a more
scientific basis
terrific well I mean it's it's there are
really exciting things happening in
genetics and neurobiology right now and
really looking at the ways in which
difference just not just illnesses but
social conditions and social pressures
can actually lead to actual brain
changes you know there was a lot of
promise in the development of
pharmaceuticals particularly with the
advent of newer generation of anti
psychotics and anti depressants and we
know from history that there's a kind of
natural trajectory of the way that these
own that these medications come out and
are accepted so initially we say these
are cures for everything under the Sun
and there's this dramatic rise and then
we say wait a minute these don't work
for anything which i think is happening
with the SSRI antidepressants right now
and then we kind of figure out a
moderated use of well they're good for
some conditions and not for others and
so again as I say I think that there's a
a give-and-take that's part of the
process and part of it is based in
science but I also think you know the
1990s were often called the decade of
the brain and psychiatry where we didn't
need to worry about Freud or about
gender psychoanalysis context all these
things were in certain ways kind of
pitched out the window because we were
going to get the answer to everything
from brain scans and I think psychiatry
itself has come to in a way like
medications are more moderated
understanding of the brain itself is
very important but you don't really know
anything about the brain unless you know
about social context expectations stigma
as other kinds of things and so
hopefully these findings will continue
to be understood in in social context
you